des jeunes filles ou des jeunes garçons
qui vont chez l'entraîneur et dans
d'autres sports je lis aussi les
journaux il y a eu beaucoup de de
problématiques dû effectivement à ce
genre de comportement des fois ça se
passe mal ou ça peut bien se passer mais
c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose qu'il
faudrait totalement éviter de mon point
de
vue
Anel je retourne un tout petit peu en
arrière a été hébergé au domicile même
de Lyonnel hor terre où certains faits
se sont produits il l'aurait installé
chez lui pour superviser au plus près sa
préparation et son hygiène de vie dans
la perspective des Jeux olympiques de
Rio la Fédération savait-elle et
acceptait-elle qu'un entraîneur héberge
un athlète chez lui pour superviser sa
préparation ben je pense que oui de
toute façon c'était encore une fois
c'est on retombe toujours dans ce qui
serait dans un monde parfait moi je suis
le premier à dire qu'il faut éviter et
tout ça aujourd'hui je peux vous citer
des cas je diraiis pas les noms ou c'est
des parents qui nous quand g sououlier
leur essaye de leur faire comprendre que
c'est pas bien d'aller mettre leur
filles chez un entraîneur et ou un
garçon hein prenons
soyons et dans ce cas-là les parents
disent ah ben si vous m'embembêtez pour
pas dire un gros mot on va le faire
émanciper comme ça vous aurez rien à
dire quoi alors que c'est un enfant
mineur après c'est toute la difficulté
aussi he d'arriver à faire comprendre
les choses parce que c'est mon point de
vue et je je suis attaché à ça mais mais
c'est vrai que c'est des fois compliqué
très compliqué alors vous avez dit
essayer de faire comprendre et que c'est
compliqué donc ça veut dire que à
l'heure actuelle vous avez un corps des
nageurs ou des nageuses qui sont
hébergés chez leur entraîneur je je
pense qu'il y en a de moins en moins
nous c'est une préconisation que l'on
donne c'est un travail qu'on a on a
parlé avec Julien isoulier donc on veut
mettre pour les structures du plan de
performance fédérale on veut mettre ça
comme une obligation mais c'est
effectivement un changement de culture s
aujourd'hui il existe encore des gens
hébergés chez leur entraîneur ça existe
il faut que ça disparaisse et c'est un
c'est un long chemin parce
qu'économiquement on on reste dans la
natation qui a un sport basé sur le
bénévola et qui peut être extrêmement
complexe financièrement pour les famille
de trouver une structure d'accueil
aujourd'hui dans nos structures du PPF
on demande à ce qu'il y ait des
internats qu'il y ait des crêpes en
support de manière à
sécuriser tout le dispositif à des coûts
relatif si demain on dit à tout le monde
c'est terminé je pense qu'on va avoir un
trou dans la raquette générationnelle